you've got two pipes going into a tank
so again I'm going to draw it and again
i'm going to see if i can simplify
things a little bit okay so here's my
tank I've got one pipe is in another
pipe in okay and we're considering what
happens when each one fills up the tank
okay so if i use both tests both
panchala five punts they tell me it
takes 80 minutes to fill up okay now
instead of writing down 80 minutes i'm
going to write this in hours because in
a second they're about to give me units
in terms of hours I'm trying to make
this easy to solve so if I can choose
between big units you know 80 120 blah
blah or small units like forever three
then I'm going to choose small ones okay
then they tell you information about the
other two pipes individually they say at
a small pipe and then the larger part
okay now at this point you must
introduce a variable okay you must
introduce a variable but you have a
choice which one would you like it to be
ok so I'm going to use T for time ok i'm
going to say the large pipe takes two
hours which means the small pipe which
takes longer is going to be tips plus
two hours now whichever you do you've
got to be consistent but i don't this
way cuz i don't know i just like
positives on recess clever ok so there
you go there's my numbers right now just
like before we have a problem in that
it's hard to deal with these quantity
because they are times much easier to do
with these if you have rates ok which is
why later or one of the topics in
calculus is rates of change because
they're easier to work with the tires so
if i consider a tank of volume v ok
volume v let's just think about this and
climb up the ladder ok if it takes T
hours to fill up with this large pie and
the whole volume is V V leaders what's
the rate going in of this one down
here what's the rate it's going to be
volume over tea right because if you
think about it suppose I had 100 liters
and takes in two hours I'm going to go a
hundred divided by 2 to get 50 liters
per hour does that make sense yes feed
is velocity over time is another way to
think about the v / t for this for this
large part what about for the small pipe
it's going to be the same volume but
it's going to be a longer time and look
this makes sense a larger denominator
means a smaller number overall because
the smaller pipe is slower alright how
about both types it's going to be V over
40 and three that's a fraction on a
fraction just going to flip it over
that's going to be 3 V on four okay
mixes or it behold on large part large
most all pipe both pipes these two rates
should be equal to this red right when I
put them together it's what adding what
I'm turning both in what does so v / t
plus v / t plus two should be three be
on four and now you can see why it
doesn't matter what the volume is
because the question is the same
irrespective of volume just like last
time so if cancer now on my volumes so
now I have this and now all I need to do
is to convert this into the appropriate
quadratic equation how shall I do that
common denominator multiply through to
get rid of those kinds of things i'm
going to multiply through by 4t squared
plus 2t that'll take care of the for the
T square plus 2t will get rid of this I
should end up with a four outside of t
plus to their 14 there and a 3t squared
plus 2t there I think from there what's
going to happen you've got to get a
quadratic of some kind right don't move
if I've got it right written down
correctly you should simplify out
there's going to be a 3t squared there
you're going to end up with this and
when you go and pull out the formula on
that one of your solutions will be
negative and the other one will be T
equals 2 so one pipe will take two hours
and the other will take their